oui mais c'est loin d'être calme
actuellement aux etats-unis dans le
midwest américain les tornades les plus
violentes se produisent au moins 2000
son lycée mais comme vous le voyez sur
ces images spectaculaires là il ya eu
énormément de tornades au cours des
derniers jours on s'en va directement
dans le midwest américain joindre marque
remillard des pionniers de québec vortex
associations de chasseurs de tempête
bonjour monsieur myard bonjour donc une
vingtaine d'états américains qui sont en
alerte
actuellement ou où vous vous trouvez
actuellement alors pour moi je suis dans
l'oklahoma
un petit peu à l'ouest oklahoma city
très bien et quelle est la situation
on a une journée en fait une journée
plutôt d'accalmie aujourd'hui par contre
on se prépare pour une journée vraiment
mouvementée de la cour lundi
ça peut être assez dangereux c est entre
le port une bonne portion du texas et de
clown
vous allez souvent faire la chasse aux
tornades si je peux dire aux etats-unis
est-ce que ça en ce moment
on vit vraiment une période plus intense
qu'à l'habitude on une année
particulièrement intense je pense en
fait c'est qu'on soit avoir un impact
une des vents d'altitude qu'on voit
plutôt en hiver avec l'humidité qu'on
retrouve au mois de mai donc c'est ça
donne un cocktail plutôt explosif faire
dans le secteur ici le même par rapport
même si on se trouvait à l'endroit où ça
arrive assez souvent les tornades au
mois de mai en ce moment on a des vents
d'altitude dumont supporter encore plus
de tornades ou encore des tomates qui
sortent
j'ai regardé les chiffres depuis le
début de l'année à plus de 300 tornades
qui ont été signalés aux états unis
vingt-trois personnes qui sont mortes en
alabama au mois de mars
vraiment on voit que c'est une saison
assez forte quelles mesures sont prises
actuellement pour protéger la population
vous êtes que ça va être intense surtout
au cours des prochaines journées
ouais en fait la plupart des gens sont
au courant alors que que de l'aide je
tenterai violence en lien le service
météo ici le l'apec la marche
mais c'est aux états unis est assez en
fait ça fait plusieurs jours le qui
parlent de cette journée le lundi et dix
jours je suis donc les gens ici sont
assez sont assez avertis quand même
ils savent aussi comment réagir face à
ces phénomènes le maintenant on a parlé
un prêt des gens il dit si hier on le
redit affaires de porter une attention
particulière pour le dis parce que ça
laisse à l'état 7 pour un chasseur de
tornades comme vous acquérez ça comprend
aussi des risques là vous n'êtes pas à
l'abri non plus oui c'est sûr puis si
pour ce que la journée de lundi ne fait
presque plus que prendre parce que
finalement c'est les orages qui vont des
orages des tornades qui vont se déplacer
à proche de 100 kilomètres/heure donc
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
facilement suivre sa propre réseau
routier qui va suivre l'attend pas être
directement dans la bonne direction
on est vraiment qu'il faut chardy nord
ce dès ce soir c'est qu'on doit qu'on
nous a dit xavier dans les routes ça
peut devenir très dangereux donc forme
fois mais vraiment faire très attention
ne fonctionne
parlez-moi plus concrètement de ce que
vous faites monsieur myard quand vous
savez que les tornades qui s'en vient de
quelle façon vous vous y prenez en fait
on nous ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
partir
on va tous du québec convoite une
période active qui le composent sont les
modèles météo parce qu'on va faire nos
prévisions nous mêmes
et puis on va se déplacer puis on arrive
aux états unis on fait nos prévisions
plusieurs jours à l'avancé on va se
déplacer en conséquence à peu près ça
fait un des leaders et des hors des
routes là on est à dire à kansas city on
sait d'avancé ce jour le jour -
sud-ouest du nebraska où est ce qu'on a
vu plusieurs tornades enchères que l'on
mehmedi vidéo sur nos plages donc c'est
ça ça va se passer le souffle vraiment
suivre la situation on est équipé dans
les voitures pourront tout le temps
internet et puis d'abord même accès aux
modèles météo les radars il faut
vraiment avoir en fait les moyens de
pouvoir comme je parlais d'un cocktail
météo qui vaut qu'il faut comprendre
l'instabilité du midi des lives en
altitude
c'est tout ça qu'on doit en fait trouvé
l'endroit où est ce que
je serai combiné pour pouvoir donner les
merlus se détend donc c'est ce qu'on va
faire en fait acheté à tous les jours
pour trouver les endroits où ça pourrait
se passer
et vous qu'est ce qui vous motive le
plus c'est ce que c'est là la passion
est ce que c'est de recueillir des
données sur le terrain
qu'est ce qui vous amène à faire ça moi
personnellement c'est vraiment plus pour
une question d'image mais c'est d'avoir
une meilleure image possible
on essaie de rester en sécurité mais
devant des images assez impressionnant
on sait personne non seulement pour la
science au québec quand on fait ça on
espère pouvoir aider en cercle sur des
environnements canada aussi en même
temps que leur confirmer ce qu'on voit
sont terrés parce que même ici là on
peut faire des rapports en fait si on
veut tenir informé en vaut deux or ont
affirmé les autorités
donc c'est sûr que l'apport de notre
part enfermant dans tout ça c'est ce
qu'on peut faire sinon c'est vraiment
une pour moi motivation ça se fait
vraiment comment les meilleures images
passées dit de m'améliorer d'année en
année permettant d'aller plus proches ou
dans des mères poussent sur moi tout en
prenant certaines mesures de sécurité
nous sans vous image a d'ailleurs qu'on
voit actuellement à l'écran c'est assez
impressionnant merci martin rue mignard
un des pionniers de québec vortex
chasseur de tornades merci d'avoir été
avec nous
merci beaucoup enfin